then the former national will crow crow
looks for his first major league win in
his seventh big league start
oh craig goes up to get it fires to
second for one and they almost turn what
looked to be an impossible double play
but there you get a look
at what will craig offers over at first
base with the glove caught up there and
then fired a bullet
look at that timing on that jump and a
head high bullet
right the newman
what looked like it might be extra bases
or at least a single
anthony diesclaffini this season his
seventh start
two in one with the 2.4 era 41 in the
third innings pitch 36 strikeouts in 10
walks great ratio there
here's polanco kicks the leg and throws
and a slider he went around strike three
swinging the home plate umpire made the
call himself piece gohfani ultimately
gets through it vermont wade junior
activated off the injured list today he
missed 25 games with a left oblique
strain
and he gets
another lefty batter on an inside
fastball strike three call that's that
fastball in i think he was trying to go
away but
pulled it over the inner
edge of the plate froze lamont
here's the pitch
right in there strike three call duggar
caught looking on the fastball crow
gives out a little weak two out single
and leaves it right there anthony
schlafani back to work in the bottom of
the third
ain't gonna miss good morning good
afternoon and good night will crow
that's a big league slider kid
will crow's thinking this is going to be
a one-nothing game and i'm going to hit
the home run
3-2 pitch and that one he definitely
went around strike three swinging
good hard slider down and in
he got frazier to chase
[Music]
two down and the fourth declining
strikeout
two balls two strikes longoria at first
with one out no score
fourth inning pitch and it's swinging
the fly ball out to left
and gammel able to dive and make the
catch headlong in left center for the
second out
it's a really nice catch by ben gamma we
talked about this when
when the pirates picked him up the
energy that he brings out in the
outfield the way he plays goes after
ball sacrifices his body does it right
here
[Music]
nice diving catch
the pitch
strike three call
i thought that changeup would drop out
of the zone except he threw him the
fastball for will crow four strikeouts
so far tonight
will crow
has permitted two singles
ground ball right up third and cooley
fielded by gonzales good stretch by
craig and they get the out
i've seen craig
spring training they do the splits over
there i mean he's so nimble he doesn't
look it though he kind of looks like a
bowler
he's an athlete but he's so good over
there
so duggar struck out looking in the
second
and duggar slams one to right hit very
well very well
and out of here
tucker goes right center field and the
giants take the lead it's one nothing
it's his first home run of the year
so it looked like he got a fastball in
and he hammered it into the bleachers in
right center field
fastball in down and in
watching crow watch that one go out of
the park as
he was wishing mightily that it wasn't
going to make it and it made it into the
third row giants with the stephen duggar
home run on the board now two straight
two out singles mike talkman and buster
posey good chance here with mike
kustremski coming up for the third time
will crow
for the giants to add on to their one
nothing lead
that one with posey or with talkman
rather taking a big lead stallings tried
to pick him off and he throws it away
mike talkman
even just the threat is gonna come in to
score two nothing
yeah an rti run thrown in gotta love
that stat right there jacob stallings
really good behind the plate defense is
definitely his forte
talkman gets off the bag a little too
much he's got the lane to throw it
and ends up just throwing it right into
the runner almost hits talkman's right
talkman in the back he dives back in and
giants get a run out of it
that one is yanked to right field toward
the corner it is a fair ball past the
lunge of polanco
so posey will walk in to score
yastremski meanwhile with his speed
racing around the third and he's in
there with a triple
well he got that ball in the air you
said that he's hit on the ground the
first two times up and that was a tough
pitch to elevate there because will
craig comes up bidding for his first
major league hit
hard hit by craig toward right center
field and clear the deck with a
cannonball and there's the first
for will craig
pirates are on the board
well he didn't hit that one very high
either
oh man how fired up is he right now like
a line drive out of here his first major
league home run
his first
major league start in this ballpark
that's the thing of beauty right there
he is fired up
but that's his fourth home run and what
about five days
four days i had two in one game so i
guess it's four in three games
wow
that's it
will craig would like that at some point
called up today
as philip evans was placed on the
injured list
the big man goes yard came in in the
upper 90s and went out at 107.
interesting situation here because we're
normally used to seeing jake mcgee pitch
the ninth but did gabe kappa asking
tyler rogers to get the last three outs
it's brian reynolds to lead things off
he
let off the seventh with a double
right back to rogers and the overhand
throw to first one out
tap back to rogers again
overhand to first two down now you got
to make some pitches to gonzales
tuckman
and that's the ball game
so the giants
get into pittsburgh game one of a
four-game series anthony discovany
beats the pirates for just the third
time in his career